Boom,
boom,
boom.
What's up,
Ben?
How are you man?
Great.
Thanks for coming here man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for extending the invitation.
Well,
I love your Instagram.
It's very,
it's very informational and tell everybody what you do so people get a handle on
this first.
Um,
uh,
I'm a non permissive environment specialists.
Basically I teach people how to live,
move and travel in places where they probably shouldn't be traveling.
Um,
you know,
how to get out of handcuffs,
how to get out of zip ties.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I show people how to survive in such environments.
Um,
my background is in law enforcement in Mexico.
So,
you know,
I spent a lot of time down there and,
um,
over the years that's kind of led me into teaching myself how to survive in that
environment.
And,
uh,
apparently after awhile that,
made me kind of a low sought after as far as teaching other people how to
survive in such environment.
So I've been doing that,
uh,
for a while here in the u s military law enforcement,
civilians,
all,
yeah.
And you started working in law enforcement.
What year?
Uh,
it's 2004.
2004.
And you started before everything got really crazy.
Yes.
Uh,
so you can,
you can kind of trace backwards.
It officially kicked off,
uh,
by the,
the start of the,
uh,
Phillipe it caused the runes presidency,
which is the,
uh,
the second to last president.
We had,
uh,
he basically said,
you know,
full on war against the cartels.
Um,
and by that time I was Kinda just getting done with my training,
um,
in northern Mexico as a a police officer and what I thought was going to be,
you know,
community policing and stuff like that turned into a full on,
here's a assault rifle and just go climb up on that Tommy with those military
guys and let's go arrest cartel members.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So you thought you were just getting a regular law enforcement Gig,
but yeah,
I mean realistically there was no such that sort of kind of job description.
This was post nine 11.
I was actually in Med school and that,
uh,
the economy and all over the border with the,
tightened security and stuff like that kind of went down,
you know,
down the drain.
And most of,
uh,
most of the money that I was using for med school,
you know,
went away.
And,
uh,
you know that in the newspaper,
Young,
unmarried individuals that don't have any kids,
you,
you're welcome to join type thing.
Young unmarried individuals with no kids.
They want that specifically.
Yeah.
That was probably a big alarm mills should the center in my head,
but the,
uh,
um,
the,
you know,
there were,
there weren't a lot of opportunities for somebody my age there that didn't have
a career.
And I thought it would be,
you know,
everybody said,
don't go,
you know,
but yeah,
I wouldn't say that was your friend though.
I'd be like that.
But it was,
it was,
to me,
it was a challenge.
Uh,
and a lot of people said I couldn't do it,
and I did it.
And then it turned into something that wasn't what most most expect,
that when they went into it and it was a full on urban warfare type situation.
Wow.
So post nine 11,
the borders get tightened up and the economy gets very bad in the border towns.
Is that what happens because people can't get through as easily?
Uh,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
it's heightened security.
So commerce isn't a,
is freely done on both sides.
A Border Wade said you should take an hour now would take three hours or four
hours depending on the time of day.
So,
you know,
things got affected.
Um,
also,
you know,
a worldwide recession,
a situation kind of happened.
So everything kind of went down.
Toilet,
you know,
I have a lot of family in the border region and all like most of our family
businesses that,
uh,
that we had,
you know,
basically kinda tanked and that during that time,
so from nine 11 two,
here we are 18 years later.
It's been a pretty radical change.
Yes.
Safe to say yes.
100% change.
Like what if you had to like try to describe it?
So,
I mean,
uh,
basically they,
the,
the part of the country that I had most of my experiences,
the Baha Sonora Juarez type region in northern Mexico.
Basically what happened is that all the cartels started fighting for the most
rich drug routes on the planet.
Um,
one of them,
of course,
being the city of Tijuana.
So the city of Tijuana is,
that's the corner of Latin America.
It's the most,
it's the most cross border on the planet.
And with that,
you know,
there's a lot of commerce that goes on in that region.
A lot of things that chip to Tijuana and then dropped Jovan up into,
into San Diego.
And a lot of people have businesses on both sides and amongst,
uh,
among all of this a movement,
you know,
there's a giant organized crime war going on and it used to be over,
like on the streets,
uh,
mid middle of the day you would see these cartel convoys,
arriving at a restaurant,
all the cartel guys outside with her a case and stuff like that.
This was 2004,
2005 era.
Um,
and what,
what is the military or law enforcement attitude towards that?
Like how did they,
so we go back to 2004 when I first got started and it was look the other way.
Really?
Yes.
Look the other way.
Look the other way was specific instruction that you got.
Uh,
it was one of those things where I went there and I got a,
I got a firearm.
Here you go,
here's your glock 17.
Uh,
here,
you two magazines a here's your Mazda 500.
And uh,
you see all those cars over there.
We don't ask them for anything,
let them pass.
That's,
you know,
we don't do anything.
Wow.
That nature.
And then it would see members of the military as well.
Kind of a go the other way,
type situation to this 2004.
Do you think that this was just to avoid conflict or what was it because of
corruption?
It's,
it's always corruption.
I mean,
it always levels at [inaudible],
all those types of levels down there.
During this time,
there was a lot of corruption.
Um,
things changed,
but you know,
things in a way,
in some levels are always the same.
Uh,
there's definitely some sort of pact going on,
some sort of fear based packed during that time.
And uh,
when,
uh,
Felipe,
he called the wrong,
finally said,
you know,
enough is enough.
We're going to declare war.
Uh,
he basically militarized a lot of the kind of narcotic efforts in Mexico.
So the military went from being,
you know,
in their,
um,
bases or manning stations out there to actually actively going out and looking
for cartel cells and trying to eliminate them.
Right?
Uh,
so basically army on the street type situation.
And another thing he did was basically all of the police chief.
A lot of the police chiefs around the country were being traded out for former
military officials or,
or military guys,
uh,
officers.
One of them was Lieutenant Colonel Lee's Ella.
Uh,
I dunno if you're,
maybe your audience is audience could look him up and he's a very famous
lieutenant colonel from Mexico x.
He has a documentary on him called Mexico's most of the bravest man.
Very,
pretty interesting guy.
Um,
he was the one that,
uh,
headed us up.
He directed us at the start of this,
these operations gets to cocktails.
And he basically said,
you know,
this is a,
this is in the policing problem.
This is a counter insurgency problem.
So we're going to,
whoa,
we're going to militarize it basically.
And after he kind of took control everything,
everything in it changed,
you know,
there weren't of the cartels went to as a verb as they were,
so he started going under ground.
So when you joined,
you expected it to be regular law enforcement when it became this counter
insurgency militarized effort against the cartels.
Was there ever a time where you were like,
I gotta get the fuck out of this job?
This is too dangerous?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
uh,
my generation,
I was part of this seventh generation of,
of,
uh,
officers go going through this,
this program,
uh,
policing and out of my generation,
the first year we had two of them in jail for corruption charges and three dead,
you know,
just out of how many out of a 23 guys.
So just 23 guys to in jail,
five gone,
a w,
two of them,
very dramatic.
That's two of them were kind of the origins of how I got into the whole counter
abduction type thing.
Uh,
two of my guys got to picked up outside of a hotel in the downtown,
the Quanta,
and,
uh,
by,
by cartel members dressed as federal police,
police officers.
That whole nine jars is the uniforms,
the car,
everything cloned.
They got,
uh,
they got asked for their papers outside and got put into a van.
They found the day later,
you know,
uh,
horribly mutilated and all this type of stuff.
Tortured,
tortured,
you know,
and that kind of,
that was the,
this is real,
this is real.
And I should probably have a,
you know,
escape plan.
And,
uh,
but it,
it wasn't a,
I didn't know anything else,
basically.
So it wasn't like I had something to fall back on and it was good pay for what
it was and yeah.
But feared that that's when fear got,
you know,
the stress must be insane.
Yeah.
It's,
you're always on,
you know,
uh,
there's,
you know,
we prototyped this thing on the,
on the meeting wall.
It said there's no vacation.
Even when there's vacation,
you know,
you would go on vacation,
you would get your gun to go on vacation.
Of course.
Yeah.
It was pretty insane.
Now,
have you ever been confronted?
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah,
of course.
I mean,
there's no,
there's the,
uh,
it's not,
you know,
I have a lot of friends that are in a military up here in the u s
and it's not like a,
it's not like them,
they go off overseas and they do something in a different country with different
people with don't speak the same language.
I was doing all of this in the place I grew up rule,
right.
So I knew some of these people at times,
you know,
I,
um,
we,
uh,
every now and then I would say,
Hey,
I know that guy from when I was a kid or we were in school together and now he
has a plate carrier where they,
and Ak 47 and a gold gun on his bands.
Right?
And it's like,
Whoa,
eh,
the gold guns,
big giveaway,
all gold guns or you know,
that's how,
you know.
Yeah,
there's some amazing websites that document all the different stuff that the
cartel house,
but they love gold guns.
Yeah.
That's a heel.
Chapo got like a gold,
a very special goals gun.
When he was a,
when he was named a one,
uh,
one of the top earners in Forbes,
the Forbes list,
I think he got his number on the gun and everything.
The second to last time he got caught because he got caught a lot of times in
this case,
uh,
somebody,
somebody in the military that got him,
took it,
you know,
and it ended up in the museum.
I think it's,
I think it's in a museum somewhere in Mexico City where a lot of these gold guns
at the ward trophy for those guys.
Right.
So this is like a gold gun section of the museum.
Yes.
Areas.
Mexican Mexico City.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's pretty wild.
Uh,
gold gun.
Goldacre AK 47.
Now,
if everything is so corrupt on there,
how does a guy like El Chapo keep getting popped?
I mean,
cause when I,
when I saw his escape,
yeah,
I was like,
this is hilarious.
The fact that this guy goes to the toilet and then he opens a door and boop,
he's in a tunnel and on an electric scooter and goes a mile pops up on the other
side and they had everything set up for them with electricity.
Like,
uh,
I mean,
you know,
the,
uh,
I think the,
the thing that people kind of don't understand about the corruption is it's not
just corruption because people are greedy.
It's all good.
It's also fear based corruption.
So if you don't do what I say,
we're going to kill everybody in your family,
even your dog,
that type of thing.
So,
uh,
after the whole Chapo got it escaped that last time,
um,
you know,
all of the staff at the jail got put in prison and so they were all part of it.
There's rumors that they were,
you know,
um,
was like somebody had to hear all that digging.
Of course.
I mean,
it's only a mile away.
They,
well,
it was pretty deep.
Yeah.
Uh,
some,
some things that should have been patrolled.
Warren patrolled,
uh,
it was a pretty good,
well made tunnel for what it was really well made.
So a lot of the people that old chapel actually used for these tunnel operations
because the same people that he used for the tunnels in the border region,
all the active tunnels that are somewhere,
you know,
along the border.
Uh,
all of those guys were pulled in from,
uh,
from,
silver mining companies that used to operate all over Mexico that kind of went
into the toilet.
So they were looking for jobs and wow,
get el Chapo out.
Good job.
That's Lauren or drug titles.
You know,
when you saw all that shit,
go down with Sean Penn and Sean Penn visiting El Chapo and Sean Penn writing an
article for rolling stone like arts.
Were you like,
what in the fuck is going on here?
Uh,
yes.
for a lot of PR.
Some reasons that might not be,
you know,
mainly was why are they giving him,
uh,
why are they giving him this celebrity status?
You know,
uh,
there's a lot of glorification and a lot of,
you know,
people venerating some of these people down there,
and they do a lot of harm,
you know,
so then you're basically giving a voice to somebody.
It would be the equivalent of somebody up here giving a voice to somebody that
was responsible for a lot of damage done to the u s you know,
it's,
why do you think they did that?
Like what,
what,
what was the Roman,
there was,
it was romantic.
Right?
There's something about it.
It's like,
here's Sean Penn,
one of our biggest movie stars.
Yeah.
One of the biggest drug dealers ever.
I mean,
he is a El Chapo down because I been to see an LOI and I've done classes there,
which was pretty surreal.
Um,
he is,
uh,
he's a folk hero.
He's,
uh,
he's,
he's Robin Hood basically to these people.
And like,
uh,
when this surreal moment that I had down there striving along this
bad bumpy ride highway and all of a sudden turn into a nice,
that kind of highway.
And,
uh,
the guys that I was told me,
Oh yeah,
this is the cartel made this highway and the back part of it,
that's the government,
the part of the highway for this,
you know,
uh,
schools,
careers,
lawyers,
doctors,
all their careers paid for by blame cartel,
immigration processes of people that want to come over here.
Sponsorships,
all type of stuff on both sides.
Right.
So the,
the span of influence,
that's,
you know,
that's how he kind of got to where he was.
He was always helping people and he was investing in people and these people,
this is,
these investments would pay later on,
you know,
in a lot of ways it sounds like he,
he benefited them.
He benefited some aspects of the community.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
the,
the reason why the military couldn't get them,
you get people said could take irruption,
but because the,
he was basically,
he had a,
a human shield around them,
you know,
all these towns owed,
schools,
hospitals,
every,
uh,
instead of Christmas down that they celebrate the day of the Kings,
you know,
um,
so they would get presents mother's Day,
they would all get presence,
that type of thing.
So why would we want to help them nudge Harry come in here and gala Chapo or
he's doing this type of stuff,
you know,
that's,
and that is the same all over Mexico with some of the cartels,
you know,
they,
uh,
hearts and mind carton minds type approaches.
What makes some of these groups,
you know,
long lived.
So how much of an effort is there to eradicate the cartels?
Because if you can get a guy like El Chapo,
who at least in terms of like popularity's at the time,
is he at the top of the list,
let's put our popularity.
But at the top,
he's at the top of the list as far as popularity.
But when,
as far as like the actual drug dealers is here at the top of the list or their
more clever folks at Hyde underground.
Yeah,
there's,
there's rumors of people above them that are still out there somewhere.
That's what everybody like that's the great conspiracy.
Is that like El Chapo is basically the bank manager that,
well,
you know,
there's a,
he has a,
a compadre a compadre somebody that if you're the daughter,
if you're the godfather of my,
my kid,
you're my compadre.
Right.
So he has a compadre out there,
uh,
and mio,
some Baba,
um,
and he is still out there.
Right.
And the,
uh,
the extent of how he works and where he works is unknown.
So He's more slick.
Exactly.
He tries to stay more low key.
Well,
uh,
there's,
you know,
some people get sick with the fame,
probably you want to go outside.
Well,
once that the TV show narcos came on,
yeah.
Then every,
well with people,
I don't,
I think there's a lot of people who did not realize how crazy the life of Pablo
Escobar was and what really went down in Columbia.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's crazy.
Uh,
Paul Escobar was a single,
you know,
he was a phenomenon in this time and age,
but he was one man,
I'll imagine replicating that type of insanity over the span of Mexico.
And it's about eight or nine guys,
you know,
that was the 90s,
early two thousands,
uh,
because these guys were,
you know,
Legion of doom type thing where they would be enemies,
but they would have reunions and they would meet up and kind of agree on,
you know,
certain terms and stuff.
Just like in,
in the Pablo Escobar show.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So they really do that.
They get together and have meetings and sometimes they kill each other.
That's,
that's the,
uh,
that's a reality.
You know,
they,
they do and at times or did at times because things are currently after all
Chapo,
you know,
things kind of shifted and changed.
What happened?
Uh,
well,
main thing is a power vacuum and with a power vacuum and,
um,
legalization on this side of certain substances,
substances like,
uh,
marijuana.
Um,
the,
the pot fields are now poppy fields and,
and new new things like,
um,
like,
like them now dedicated themselves to heroin instead of,
uh,
instead of the weed was,
but seriously,
they're still,
we'd fields down there for some reason.
You guys are way better at making it than anybody time there,
but for some reason they're still is with wheat fields.
But I think it's a lot of access,
especially in the states where it's prohibited.
Yeah.
Just,
they're probably more willing to get it to the people's probably it,
uh,
math,
math precursors being brought in from China and to Mexico or now being made in
Mexico,
like industrial level stuff.
Right.
And I knew up a new upsurging cartel down there that is trying to overtake the
senior lawyer cartel,
the new generation carto as coming out of Wallet Hora and they're kind of really
militarized kind of wing of a cartel activities that are trying to,
you know,
take control over the whole thing.
What is the plan in terms of the government?
I mean if they,
if they can take out a guy like El Chapo,
what is the plans to eradicate all this and is there really a plan to eradicate
it or is it one of those things where it's sort of a plan on paper,
but realistically they sort of accept the fact they're never going to get rid of
these people?
So,
uh,
I have,
like I have a thing like that.
Like basically,
uh,
[inaudible] was a feather Turpin and I have a image of a feather to Chirp and
biting itself.
Mexico has a problem with Amnesia,
a six year cycle of Amnesia.
Every president comes in and has all these plans to eradicate the cartels.
President goes out,
nobody likes him anymore.
New Guy comes in and says,
well,
I have a better plan.
You know,
and that's the cycle we always go through.
So it's a big issue in Mexico.
Yeah.
And current.
Currently we have a leftist president that doesn't want to have anything to do
with the past
administration that are more on the right of the spectrum.
His name is Andres Manuel Lopez.
Obrador.
I'm low,
uh,
vocally supporting Venezuela,
um,
that,
that type of guy.
Apparently he has a good relationship with the,
with Trump.
Uh,
that's,
that's what people say.
Uh,
but his whole thing was amnesty for the cartels.
That's a campaign promise.
Amnesty.
Yes.
And what does that mean exactly?
Nobody knows what that means.
That's what he was saying.
That was,
you have a plan for amnesty or is it just like a statement a,
it was a statement.
And now if you see a counter narcotics operations throughout the country,
they,
uh,
the military is not as active as it used to be.
Whoa.
Uh,
some of the cartels are growing in influence,
um,
because of amnesty could be,
you know,
uh,
basically I don't see the efforts that were there,
when I was active down there.
Oh,
things change,
you know,
so I don't know.
I,
I truly think that the absurd because we're,
we're on route of B two to having the most violent year in Mexico as far as a
cartel related deaths.
Right.
Um,
when I got out do you want to had been on the top most dangerous cities on the
planet list and I actually worked there when it was on the top and through
efforts both for the,
from the government and,
and through people like a Lieutenant Colonel Leyzaola,
uh,
Tijuana was gone off the list of most dangerous cities in the world.
And now it's again at number one,
right?
Yeah.
You sent me that.
I was pretty shocked because you don't hear about that here.
It's a six murders at night.
You know,
I was down there,
uh,
two days ago and it was,
it's a basically cartel on cartel,
so they're cleaning each other out and just bodies appear in the morning,
you know,
and um,
bridges hung from bridges,
um,
towards your shot.
You know,
that's,
you know,
but again,
the,
there's nobody's doing anything about it that should,
you know,
but it's kind of turning a blind eye and a lot of ways.
And so with this leftist president,
this guy who has this idea of amnesty,
the people that are in charge of handling the cartel,
the,
the military and the police officers,
they've got to feel like a little abandoned.
Yeah.
Or maybe some of them don't have a business plan and they're working at one
side.
Um,
so that's a problem too.
Yeah.
So,
so to people that aren't aware,
you know,
we have a separation of powers down there as well.
So the army constitutionally shouldn't be engaging in combating the guardrails.
They shouldn't be engaged in police roles.
But there were some amendments done to the Constitution and laws passed.
But you have to realize that some of these people that are fighting the cartels
and the policing type role from the military,
uh,
some of them can't read,
write or some of them come from rural parts of Mexico that shouldn't,
they shouldn't be doing that type of activity.
So you get a lot of,
you know,
a lot of failures on that side of the fence.
We do have some high level SF community members in Mexico that are doing the
work,
but they're few and far between.
And then you have the federal police,
uh,
which has gone through about four or five name changes in the past,
you know,
10 years,
because every time,
well,
not going to call them that and change the uniform because they're all corrupt
Jesus,
but now they're,
now they're this police.
Right.
So,
um,
so they just change appearance.
They changed the name,
you know,
but try to refresh the public opinion of it.
Yeah.
There was a famous,
uh,
you know,
modern,
uh,
investigation,
federal investigation.
Police called the coffee and they were like modern investigative federal police.
It's going to go after.
And they were corrupt as hell,
you know,
and they,
all they did was you don't get a name change.
And all these guys got shuffled around and looking around and was like,
Hey,
I know you like what?
I'm not,
no,
I'm,
I'm this now.
You know?
But they're still the same person who compromise.
Yes.
Yeah.
So those are the federal guys,
right?
Currently the,
they want to do like a national,
a national police force and you're like,
wow,
they're going to get new people that are going to be national police force.
No,
it's the same guy.
She changed the uniform,
change your hat.
So that's on the federal side,
you know.
So we're pretty,
you know,
wanting their,
uh,
state side.
Each state has their own police force,
uh,
investigation,
police force,
and a preventative type force.
And these are politicized because each state government may be opposed to the
federal government.
So there's a,
there's some static there now and each municipality has its own police force and
they meet,
it might be completely different,
uh,
politically than these state and federal.
So
it must,
for you to have your life on the line over there and see all this chaos and
obvious the lack of organization or outright corruption,
it must be insanely frustrating.
Yeah.
I mean,
well the uh,
that'd be putting people in that were clearly,
uh,
guilty of things,
you know,
and then seeing them come out or the legal system down there that I got with
that I had to endure.
You know,
you would have to go and do a face to face with all these people,
right?
Go into a Federal Court House,
leave your firearms behind,
do a face to face with these people inside that you just got a,
that you just got four,
however many tons of cocaine or pot or whatever and then go outside and they're
outside,
you know,
now,
now I know who you are.
You know,
there's no anonymity in that,
in that regard to you.
You would have to sign things,
you know,
and then seeing some of the people that were with you working on your side and
seeing how some of them would fall into corruption charges and then see what the
government and then get your jobs back.
But now you have somebody that's compromise within your own unit.
Wow.
All right.
So they,
they did try a few things to try and clean out police forces.
Um,
one of them was a planned,
they called,
uh,
the C3 plan.
It was like a,
like a filter for police officers down there.
It's still in,
it's still an action,
but you know,
it's questionable if it's effective or not.
I saw a lot of people go through it and later on Hyundai would turn out to be
cartel guys.
Basically.
They would do a background check,
FBI background check,
a polygraph exam,
a drug testing,
uh,
all the,
all of these things to see that you were,
you know,
clean to work on these police forces.
Uh,
the problem is that the polygraphs turned out to be unconstitutional to fire
somebody over them.
So a lot of these people got hired back after they would fail a polygraph basic
polygraph exam.
So yeah,
again,
it's a lot of attempts to clean it up,
you know,
and I,
you would be on the,
on the level and all these people wouldn't be on the level,
but they were still there.
So what percentage of people are not on the level?
If you had to guess roughly.
I mean,
I would say it would depend.
I'd say 30% problem.
That's a lot on,
on,
on my experience of the people that I worked at.
30% weren't on them.
You must cherish the 70.
Oh,
uh,
like family.
Yeah,
Um,
and you,
you,
you would know when some of these people weren't on level.
Because,
you know,
I have this running joke that I have this,
I,
I went in with the same car that I drove out of the office with,
you know,
a shitty truck that I had,
that I bought,
that I bought when I,
uh,
you know,
about my own dime first truck,
first car,
and I drove out of the office when they quit,
when I quit the job that same day,
you know,
I,
I drove,
I drove out of the office and that truck,
but a lot of these guys would come in with their,
you know,
hummers and h shoes and just weird cars.
Will they go,
wait a minute,
this doesn't make sense.
Like we are working the same office.
Yt Yt you have a three story house.
So obvious though.
Prove it,
you know?
Yeah.
But,
but the,
the obviousness of it,
oh yeah.
Blatant.
You're driving a nice car,
living in a big house and everybody else was like,
what?
Yeah.
Uh,
there's,
you know,
there's obviously these,
this,
that,
these unwritten rules of,
and you know,
you won't,
you wouldn't tell on this guy,
of course,
but you know,
it obvious.
Yeah.
And when it came time to share information of a certain kind,
or we're going to go over here and you would have to turn around and look around
and see who was listening,
you know?
Yeah.
You wouldn't trust a lot of these people.
So how are we gonna Power?
We're going to do our job if we can't trust the people that are working with us.
Well,
who was it that recently called for decriminalization?
They go,
was it there,
your president that called for the decriminalization of all drugs in America to
go along with Mexico?
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
Try to do something about the cartels.
We are on the brink of,
of legalizing marijuana and in Mexico right now,
like there's been a few landmark cases and you know,
it's gold rush type situation right now.
There's a lot of companies down there that get,
that have had experienced up here.
They want to go down there.
Right.
Uh,
so the culture is ready for it,
I think.
Do you think that would help?
I don't know.
When it comes to legalizing pot up here,
it hasn't helped down there as far as lowering things actually made things
worse.
How's it made things worse?
Uh,
they changed,
they changed the,
uh,
they changed what they were producing.
So that the ones you love,
the reason why there's a heroin heroin epidemic up here and fentanyl epidemic up
here,
uh,
I think has some relationship with how things got legalized up here and how they
switched,
um,
product down there.
So a lighter colored heroin is coming down from Mexico.
And I've seen [inaudible] I worked with law enforcement,
uh,
up here in the u s uh,
doing classes and kind of,
you know,
they send me things like,
what do you think about that?
Is that,
um,
and I've,
I've seen that lighter colored heroin pop up in places as far off as your
comments.
So,
you know,
because of the color.
Yeah,
the color,
the smell,
the consistency.
You can kind of tell if it's Asian or how it will cause a different strain.
Like it's,
it's a probably a different strain and it's also the amount of sun it gets in
the region where it's going to be in grown as high at higher altitude.
So it's lighter color,
not as stinky,
I dunno.
Um,
but I think it's a relationship that,
that kind of relates to the legalization issue down there.
They didn't affect them in the pockets.
They just switched the product.
It's gotta be,
it's such a strange relationship because the reason why these drug cartels have
so much power because they're selling drugs to the United States.
Yeah.
So it's like you have this connection to this country that has this great big
wall that it wants to build.
And on one side,
everybody's buying up all the illegal drugs and the other side,
everyone's killing everybody to try to make and sell these illegal drugs.
Yeah.
I mean,
and there's a lot of holes underneath that.
A wall and,
uh,
drones,
drone technology is that we're all going to help anything.
Well,
the walls already been up for a few years.
Part of it.
And in place like the [inaudible],
which is like one of the richest truck routes,
routes on the planet.
And it's the drugs that cost the same,
you know,
it's the same.
It's,
yeah.
And what about like the ocean?
Can't they just take a boat?
Uh,
I've,
I've seen one large submarine in my time working real large,
like,
like military science,
uh,
like,
like scientific size.
Where the fuck does somebody buy on submarine online?
Apparently.
Really?
Yeah.
You can buy a submarine can buy a small submarine for a small amount of money.
I think the main part of the summary and ownership is maintained maintenance.
That was the reason we found it is that it wasn't properly maintained.
So it a sunk.
He uh,
it,
uh,
it actually,
no,
it actually floated,
couldn't sink.
Oh.
And it had a bunch of things.
Hanging off
summaries scare the shit out of me.
You can't see where you're going.
Well,
so yeah,
I've seen submarines,
uh,
drones,
like a squadron of drones with a bunch of loads on it.
Wow.
How heavy can a drone get?
Still fly?
I've types I've seen for like two kilos on it.
Really?
Yeah.
So just fly in the coke over the top.
The only reason we,
I found out about those,
one of those crashed,
uh,
in a,
an a roadside next to the border fence.
Were you around when that CIA drug plane crashed in Mexico with tons of cocaine
on it?
I wasn't there,
but I was aware of that situation.
What the fuck is that about?
I mean,
realistically,
uh,
there's,
there's a lot of Americans running around in Mexico.
Yeah.
That's,
that's,
that's it.
There's a lot of cowboys,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of people say,
listen,
we just make this one run.
Like the government doesn't give a fuck about us.
My pension sucks.
It could be,
you know,
every now and then,
and this is,
this is,
this isn't a secret.
Every now and then you would see a dude out there that's blonde,
tall and has a bunch of tattoos that don't belong down there working on the
military side of things in Mexico or some dudes doing something,
some place in your [inaudible] that you would get a call,
you know.
Oh they're,
they're fine.
Just,
you know,
just leave him alone.
So who knows?
You know,
who knows.
So if it's three out of 10 were corrupt,
where you,
where it might be like one out of 10?
I have no idea.
You guys.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
usually we would get to,
since I have a pretty good,
you spoken English,
I would get a,
I will get sent places for training or for liaison work with some people that
would go down there and I would never know what the hell some of these people
were from,
you know,
so who knows,
it seems like it's very loose.
Like there's a lot of room for fuckery,
uh,
Calderon era and Bush administration era.
It,
there was a lot of,
there was a lot of stuff going on.
Uh,
Obama Administration era after,
uh,
the whole fast and furious thing,
things kind of went dark for a while,
explained the fee.
A lot of people don't know what the fast and furious series it was a the,
it's sold guns to the cartel under the guise that this is the way they would
track the guns.
Yes.
It seems so fishy.
Oh,
I learned about it from CNN and I,
a few of my friends were killed with some of those guns down there,
which is,
you know,
everybody talks about the,
the u s agent that was in Mexico has killed by some of these guns.
But there was a lot of,
you know,
Mexican agents and people civilians killed by these guns as well.
So there were very specific types of guns,
you know,
so like imagine somebody giving you a shopping list about the types of guns you
want.
Right.
Including In these lists were 50,
cal Barrett,
Gus Barrett rifles and fn five sevens,
which are a very,
it's a,
it's a pistol with a very high velocity round that goes through a soft armor.
Like the type of stuff that was issued to us.
All right.
So all of a sudden we were seeing these space best tools in the hands of the
cartels and very specific parts of the country.
And we're like,
but what a preposterous idea that they're going to sell it to the cartel track
of track them.
Well,
that sounds like horse shit to me.
That sounds like someone was trying to make money and they said,
oh,
well,
just,
uh,
say we're selling it to them to track it.
Well,
the,
the suspicious part is that all of them went to the one specific cartel that's
seen the law cartel.
So it sounds like such horseshit.
The fact that,
I mean,
who went to jail for that?
Eric Holder didn't go to jail.
He should have,
he should have.
I mean,
there's,
there's blood,
you know,
people died.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
an,
I can't say the name,
uh,
but somewhere in,
in Baja,
a little girl lost her arm.
Uh,
an agent that was a friend of mine got killed and the wife got killed with
[inaudible] that are directly related to that whole thing.
Right.
So you can go to jail for fucking tax evasion and this guy can get away with
that.
Uh,
the,
the idea that you would run that by people and they would go,
yeah,
good idea.
Yeah.
Give them gun.
And to be clear,
I don't know the,
the realities of that operation on this side.
People say there was,
it was a,
it was happening way before.
All I know is that when that happened,
nobody told us.
And there was definitely some weird resentment on part of the government down
there and some people down there as far as you know.
And,
and uh,
there was some weird conspiracy theories going on as well down there.
How could there not be?
Yeah.
I mean that seems like it's conspiracy theory right in front of your face.
Did the fact,
Oh yeah,
we just sold them to trucks or the guns so that we could track.
Um,
yeah,
no one's going to die.
It's not like a bad idea.
The main thing you would hear is that people will them in fast and furious.
Executive privilege law suit between Doj and house
are wrapped up with in the last two weeks,
I guess really this is just wrapping up some settlement.
Wow.
Cause this is from,
what,
nine years ago?
10 years ago at least.
And the guns are still showing up,
so I don't know how many of them they,
I don't,
I've never known what numbers,
but
last time we found some,
and I,
I have,
I actually have a images of the ones we found.
They were buried in somebody's backyard inside of a,
uh,
a water barrel.
And all of them were obviously us origin guns.
And they're like,
well what do you mean?
Uh,
all of them had very specific,
uh,
accessories on them that nobody else in the world puts these accessories on
their guns at us because they're pretty ridiculous accessories.
Like what kind of accessories?
Um,
things that had things,
uh,
letters on them,
like a see you in hell type things on the petitioner's punishers calls,
punish your skulls of the big one.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
and that is hilarious that a cartoon skull has from a marvel comic book cause
become a gigantic part of SPEC ops.
Yeah,
it is.
It is pretty ridiculous.
Well,
the main room or down there like conspiracy theory wise,
and you would hear all sorts of things,
you know,
uh,
because down there there's,
there's no such thing as top secret clearance in Mexico.
You know,
there's like,
Hey,
don't say anything.
That's about it,
you know?
Uh,
so you'd hear crazy,
crazy things.
Uh,
main thing was that the US was planning an invasion.
You know,
they're,
they're destabilizing the region so they could put boots on the ground.
Oh,
Jesus.
You know,
that was the,
the,
like a Colin conspiracy theory going on to us invading Mexico.
Yeah.
How fucking crazy would that be?
Well,
you know,
uh,
as far as,
a reaction on the side of Mexico,
uh,
people aren't here then.
This is,
again,
this is purely speculation and weird rumors that I would hear,
uh,
people were planning to do poison drug loads on that side,
to create a health crisis in dos as a reaction.
Uh,
that was pretty,
like when I heard it's like little league who was talking about this yet,
you know,
uh,
and so full out war almost could be,
you know,
uh,
and then you would try to see,
well,
who's doing that?
And the cartels.
So the cartels are the government at the same thing.
Like what's going on.
Right,
right,
right.
And again,
this is just weird stuff.
You,
what occurred,
this is a crazy perspective,
right?
The cartels would poison the drugs to punish the Americans for the military
invading the country.
Yeah.
[inaudible] to create a,
to create a health crisis in the u s so they would,
you know,
have to go back.
Wow.
That,
I mean,
not the rumors.
You know,
how many guns they brought over a,
I've heard all sorts of numbers.
We never got told the same as going number.
Nearly 2000 firearms were illegally purchased for 1.5 million according to the
DOJ inspector general report.
Fuck.
Hundreds of guns related recovery.
The United States and Mexico.
Yeah.
Ma 50 cows were so the,
the,
it's,
and it's always an escalation with the cartels.
Right.
So the,
we,
they would get a AK 47 and we would get a German main g three's that were saying
around the same caliber and we could fight back.
Right.
And then all of our leadership started rolling around in armored vehicles.
So let's get 50 cals to,
you know,
make holes in these armored vehicles.
So,
so it was all,
it's always been an escalation.
Now this is crazy.
You guys were getting 50 cows so you could shoot holes in the armored vehicles.
Yeah,
the,
so the cartels were getting them first and then,
uh,
then we had to get them because they were rolling around in our vehicle.
So that Mad Max hype,
armored vehicles they would make,
they would first,
first day would make them like homemade madmax armored vehicles.
Uh,
uh,
they,
they found a few of their online somewhere.
One of them was called [inaudible],
which is like a giant.
They all that all that was missing with the guy with the guitar on the back of
it,
you know,
like my Max.
Um,
and they would use these to roll into town and like,
how would you fight that?
You know?
Right.
And then we had to get a 50 cow or we'll get the military to shoot them from the
sky.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a famous video from somewhere down in Mexico where they shoot a Vulcan,
a rifle down at a cartel member and the card number vehicle.
But then you'd see,
well,
you know,
uh,
checkmate,
checkmate.
Government against the cartel.
But then you realize that the cartels like the new generation cocktail in
Guadalajara actually downed helicopters in Walla Hora military helicopters
because they have antiaircraft capabilities.
Jesus Christ.
So that then you,
now you're like checkmate cartels,
you know,
that's,
that's how,
where does this go?
Like where,
where,
I mean,
how far does it escalate?
I,
that's,
that's the,
that's the thing that,
you know,
you,
you have to think about the,
so killing and death is not
at the industrial level.
It's that is being done in Mexico,
not just killing,
but,
you know,
disappearing bodies,
making body disappear.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
I was around when they got the,
the stew maker,
the stew maker was a guy,
uh,
that worked for the senior level cartel in Tijuana,
and he would get rid of bodies using caustic soda.
All right.
So he would get bodies every night and he had these basically these industrial
level,
just barrels of it just going into caustic soda.
It's a chemical mixture.
Yeah.
You can get most of the components at a hardware store,
basically a dissolves bodies,
you know,
they would get,
get some of this,
a mixture he said in interviews,
uh,
that he got trained by Israelis that how to do that.
So who knows if that's true or not.
But in the night he said he would get rid of,
you know,
dozens of bodies and this gets rid of everything,
DNA,
bone,
everything.
So there was a lot of families on Mexico that are looking for their kids for
years and there's just no way of giving them a body.
Um,
and the amount of youth that goes into cartel working just gets,
you know,
killed there.
And it's just,
it's a whole generations and whole towns,
uh,
of women and old men,
you know,
they're out there now,
which is like coal generation is just God,
you know,
all the men in gone.
I've gone to gone to a few small towns where like they looked at me like youth,
you know,
young man.
So it's rare at some places that is because of the men are all getting killed or
getting God,
God,
God in the uh,
you know,
in the cartel operations and killed or you're recruited,
forcibly recruited or voluntarily recruited,
but you don't hold generations just wiped out.
Now the people in your line of work,
the people that are boots on the ground who really understand the problem,
what is the thought in terms of what could be done to fix this?
I think a main thing is any sort of,
uh,
any sort of plan,
any sort of plan to fight the cartels that involves just a six year plan won't
work because that's what,
that's what the main problem has been with Mexico.
Each president of your presidential
terms,
six years.
Each president comes in with a six year plan.
He either does very good or does really bad and then it gets forgotten and
another one comes in.
And,
uh,
there's also definitely an addiction to money from the u s side of four car
counter and cartel operations.
Uh,
there's a,
uh,
plan Mary that it's called.
It's a international plan where the u s pays for a count on narcotics type
operations in,
in,
in Mexico.
So there's an addiction to that money on the side of the government.
So there's a lot of interest for that to keep going,
you know,
so they don't want to resolve the problem as much as they want to in some ways,
um,
they,
they refuse to professionalize the police horses down there.
Uh,
they don't put enough effort in that,
in that regard.
You know,
good people that are there that I've,
I know there's some amazing guys down there doing amazing work,
uh,
and they get passed up for promotion because they don't,
they don't have any,
they don't know anybody high level.
Uh,
they don't work for either side of the game.
You know,
so a lot of these people just get cast aside,
you know,
and uh,
it's kind of hopeless in that regard.
You know,
a lot,
a lot of the good guys when they get,
when they come out of the job,
there's only a few options to them.
Right.
Um,
I had,
I had options,
but in a lot of the guys that go out of job Dome,
so they get recruited by the cartels.
All right.
Did anybody ever attempt to recruit you?
Yeah.
You get offers?
No.
You get off.
Um,
there's a,
there's a famous,
uh,
there's a famous called [inaudible],
which is like a Mexican folk folk song,
uh,
called,
I'm going to talk about my past.
Right.
And it's a pretty interesting songs about a cartel guy that used to work as a
cop.
And then somebody from his past approaches them and says,
you want the kids haven't done on college?
You want to,
you want to do a job,
you know,
that's what you would get.
You know,
people within the police force is asking you what you want to,
you want to work on the side.
That was the entry,
you know,
and,
or you know,
we'll pay you this much.
What does it like when you say no?
Uh,
it's pretty,
it's pretty hard.
It's uh,
it's not,
it's not specifically saying no,
but just saying,
I'm not the one to ask for this.
And you say,
you know,
I'm not the one that asked for this.
You know what,
I'm,
I'm only in this for the money,
for my paycheck and you know,
I don't want to risk anything.
So,
and how do they leave that?
They don't,
then they're not happy usually,
you know?
So if you get on a list sometimes and you know something that follows you,
but it's in a much better thing than actually going,
getting into one of these guys pockets,
you know,
once you take something,
you're theirs.
Right.
Like the mom,
like the mom,
you know,
a lot of things.
It's a lot of these guys actually took,
but you know,
they,
they have a lot of these cartels down there.
They kind of venerate the whole gangster era in the US.
It's like a thing.
Oh,
so it's like a thing they looked up like look up to,
you know.
Right.
So like you see a lot of a gold plated,
a Thompson machine guns down nurses take picture with him.
So there's a,
a lack of professionalizing the police force.
Yes.
And that you think is a conscious effort?
I think.
I think it's a,
so we keep them fairly incompetent.
I think.
So,
you know,
a lot of ways we w we were,
we were,
uh,
as a group,
the group that I used to work with,
uh,
we,
there was a lot of efforts to professionalize us to like getting,
getting that career path to actually being,
um,
you know,
making an a,
a career.
There's no,
right now where I used to work,
there was no pension.
No,
there's no retiring.
Wow.
Uh,
if you want to get any sort of a credit for anything,
the credit,
the credit companies won't even touch you because you're too high risk,
you know,
you too high risks cause you might get shot.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well it is the most dangerous city on the planet.
All right.
So,
so they,
they wouldn't touch us.
Um,
and realistically,
culturally being a cop in Mexico is,
you know,
male porn actor,
cop or probably along the same range as far as shame,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah.
Uh,
W I,
I,
we wouldn't eat at any restaurant that we didn't know the people,
you know,
because it would spit in their faces a lot of,
yeah.
There's hate and I was hate or by,
by the hate cops,
how much they like a,
as a,
as a culture in Mexico,
police,
cultural Mexico has earned it.
You know,
a lot of guys working both sides.
A lot of guys being,
uh,
you know,
um,
again,
the whole,
uh,
you're going to be a cop because you know somebody in there and the people that
shouldn't be in any sort of public service.
Uh,
so there's a lot of corruption.
Again,
a lot of corruption,
a lot of,
a lot of things done wrongly by the cops,
a lot of abuses,
you know,
a lot of human rights violation type situations.
So it's earned,
you know,
so the big shift over there in terms of crime turns with cartel crime occurs
first with September 11th,
tightening of the borders.
Then it starts to ramp up after that because of what,
uh,
the,
the government first started,
uh,
targeting certain,
cartel heads.
You cut one head off Hydra,
two headphones who had three heads pop up,
power vacuum,
our vacuum bill fight to try to gain power.
You know,
like the cartels realize,
you know what,
yeah,
that we are standing on the richest drug routes on the planet,
so we should probably,
you know,
start fighting over him.
Yeah.
And also what also what happened is that,
you know,
a lot of these people,
it's something that people,
Americans kind of don't have,
don't get yet.
This isn't a Mexican problem anymore.
Specifically as far as the cartel violence going on.
A lot of these people have their kids up here in the US in the 90s.
A lot of these cartel guys,
you know,
it'll chapel has kids,
had kids in Dos,
and a lot of these people are now coming of age,
you know,
um,
so cartel influence in the u s is a thing you're going to start seeing if you're
already seeing it,
but you're going to see more of it because a lot of these people are actually
American born US citizens now working in tandem with any sort of interest down
there.
So,
oh,
that's going to be the new shift,
you know,
and uh,
people,
people are sometimes kind of horrified by some of the stuff that I post up.
Some of the cases down there,
people can look up the [inaudible] gang in,
in southern California,
there were actual cartel,
a group that would kidnap people in the u s dressed as federal agents in the u s
and dragged them back down to Mexico.
Now this has happened a few book almost I think in like nine years back.
But this is happening to you who knew us?
No,
it's not something foreign anymore.
You know,
a lot of people want to think that you will,
you can build a wall and keep all that down.
Don't get me wrong.
People build that wall.
I have nothing against it.
But selling it as a security thing,
uh,
just,
I don't,
I don't think it makes that much sense in a lot of,
in a lot of the parts where it's,
it is up,
violence is rampant on both sides.
But if the,
the,
uh,
the argument would be that if the wall didn't exist,
then it would be too easy to come back and forth.
Okay.
Um,
at all spots.
yeah,
it could,
could,
you know,
but again,
drug [inaudible],
catapults,
drones,
uh,
drugs and in terms of what kidnapping people and a lot of other things that you
cut off at least some of the vehicle.
Yeah,
I get it.
I,
and I think,
again,
I'm not against the wall,
build the wall.
Um,
uh,
that,
I interviewed a Guy,
uh,
I do articles for a few magazines and I interviewed a guy who was a,
it's a coyote kwiyate.
He moves people from the border.
And he said this about the board was asking in the interview about the border
wall and he said,
it's good for business,
you know,
uh,
you make something seem like it's harder when it isn't and it's good for
business on.
So you say,
listen,
I can't get children 3000,
it's gotta be five and yeah,
it's tighter.
Yeah.
Or flying to Canada.
And they walked down,
which is,
that was his,
one of his,
one of his new favorite methods,
you know,
so northern United States probably got a lot of Mexicans now.
Yeah.
The candidate bulletin board is hilarious.
It's a path.
Yeah.
It's a carved out hundred yard pat.
We put pictures of it up the other day.
We're like,
look how hilarious it says the difference.
You,
Mexico and Canada,
Canada,
they make it easy to know where the border is.
Like just get across here a and it'd be fine.
Snow Mexicans,
you know?
Yeah.
It's really strange.
Well,
I mean,
it's the,
the,
the amount of creativity and problem solving that goes on,
on the,
on the criminal side,
you know,
um,
uh,
if,
if your best plan is,
is a wall of a secure wall.
These guys have been working against that best plan for the past 20 years.
So they are,
they're already way ahead of the curve in that regard.
You know,
uh,
there was an interesting time in a drunk and people can look this up.
A drone technology had a,
had an upsurge in innovation in Tijuana out of all places in the world for a
time.
You know,
like why that's funny,
you know,
wonder hmm.
And what they were doing when those,
what could be done to radically curb this,
uh,
you know,
like if you were the king of the world said,
ed,
what are we going to do?
Uh,
first off,
legalizing sums up some of the substances would probably help.
Uh,
that would help a lot.
Um,
that's a pretty good question.
But even some substances that are illegal,
like fentanyl's essentially legal because you can get a prescription for it,
but
you're never going to have like fentanyl just over the counter.
It's just too deadly.
Uh,
you know,
another thing that,
I think about,
and that's a very good question.
I wish I could answer.
Uh,
I think everybody wishes they can answer it and everyone just sorta like shrugs.
And so the,
the,
the cartels aren't just a drug fueled business.
They also have money that is in property and legitimize businesses.
Uh,
they work in human trafficking.
Like they act you if you used to be,
you can cross that border and go to the desert and cross it yourself.
But now you have to be a toll,
uh,
protection rackets across the,
on both sides of the border.
Um,
sex trafficking,
um,
piracy like,
like you name it,
they have,
they have hands on it,
right?
So,
so they're just essentially took that drug money and just diversify a crime
business,
diversified.
You know,
they've been diversified for a long time.
Like there was a recent to lead to a three,
three cartel members from Sina Loa,
uh,
in Malaysia released out of all places.
So you just think about that too.
Seeing the law cartel guys somewhere in Malaysia got caught somewhere and now
they've been released and they got it like a hero's welcome into Mexico to get a
hero's welcome.
Oh yeah.
Really,
let's see in the law that you know that again,
seeing the low as a pretty,
that's a,
I have this nickname for Mexico,
I call it the upside down,
you know,
uh,
because everything's basically upside down now.
And uh,
yeah,
these guys got funny thing is that the Mexican government was involved in their
release and then they send them back and hero's welcome.
What were they doing all the way over there and that part of the world that I
don't know,
you know,
diversifying,
diversifying.
So no one has a real plan.
Here it goes,
Malaysia pardons three Mexicans on death row.
Oh,
they were on death row,
Dan.
Um,
you want to talk about a kick ass Garrido like a folk song song about you.
Those are probably going to get an amazing folks on,
you know?
Um,
so there's a lot of romanticism.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's romanticism,
it's religion.
There's definitely some,
some,
uh,
cultism uh,
involved in a lot of the higher ups in these cartels.
Uh,
I can remember when I found out about the narco music,
these,
what are those songs called?
At CoreOS?
The folk songs.
Um,
there's a lot of them,
you know,
there's a,
and they,
all of them have a secret language in them sometimes or,
or they're all a history of something that happened and you pay somebody to,
to,
to make one for you or somebody makes it for you.
And then if you do a good choreo song for somebody and the rivals,
we'll send somebody to kill you.
You know,
so like,
even even the musicians are on either side of the cartel kind of groupings as
well,
which is pretty weird.
I know,
but it's,
wow.
So if you're,
if you're for the wrong cartel,
if you make a song,
you kind of have to like go into hiding or not play any in any places where
literally rival cartels territory.
These are,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
Will they come to your territory to come get you?
If you have?
Yeah,
there's Finna be,
have been a few high level,
uh,
singers,
Mexican folk singers that got their,
you know,
killed,
uh,
for messing with the girlfriends,
with cartel members or first thing in the wrong song in the wrong place.
Uh,
so that's in the culture and,
and the religious,
uh,
cultism of the cartels have as well.
You know,
it's a pretty interesting thing.
Um,
things like [inaudible],
Martha [inaudible] death cult that is kind of in different parts of Mexico.
It's like a,
think of a very dark,
uh,
free masonry type thing,
right?
So certain levels,
you have people that are part of the,
part of that cult from the cops to the military,
to the cartels.
It's kind of,
uh,
to,
prostitutes and drug dealers.
Uh,
it's interesting how,
how that kind of also has an influence on,
on,
on the way.
Some people go into very risky businesses like being cops or,
or are cartel guys and how they were,
are they empower themselves by,
some of these are called iconographies.
You know,
I'm like,
wow.
Or,
or,
um,
there's,
there's the trinity is the [inaudible],
which is a,
it was a folk hero from turn of the century in the law,
basically abandoned that,
got caught and killed and he turned into a Satan.
Now there's a giant church to him and Tina low with a bunch of money stuck to
the walls and um,
pictures of guys in the US with like a F150 truck or a hummer.
Like,
thank you.
[inaudible] I am living the dream now because of you.
Wow.
Eh,
to roadside altars with,
uh,
with a,
a statue of the Virgin Mary.
And then you look her and there's a reaper behind it because it's a hidden Santa
Marta,
a shrine.
And they do that too.
So the knowledge,
he doesn't destroy them because they have standing orders to destroy these
things,
which shouldn't be,
but you know,
kind of religious persecution.
But they actually do that.
It's so,
it's so different than the United States and a lot of ways it is.
I mean,
I don't think we understand like all this stuff.
I think the average person has no idea about the songs,
no idea about the culture of it all.
They have no idea the depth and how deeply it's connected to the society down
there.
I mean the death,
the death cult worship is,
I think you could probably trace it back to the Aztec days.
All right,
so there's definitely,
when you see all these highly graph,
highly violent bloody cartel executions and things like that.
I don't know.
I mean,
yeah,
I think there's some sort of genetic memory from that time of those times.
It's not abnormal physically for some of these people that do that type of
thing.
You know,
ripping somebody heart next to a tree is like,
there's videos of that stuff out there.
I remember getting contacted by people that I knew on this side of the,
uh,
of the border in the u s uh,
that were very curious of why all these people from the Middle East.
We're looking at all these cartel execution videos.
And then a few years later you had isis doing some high production execution
videos that were inspired by the cartels,
you know?
Wow.
So is that interesting that we don't think about that?
We think about,
oh my God,
look at Isis.
They're cutting people's heads off like they've learned from Mexico,
which is connected to us by labs right down there.
Fucking walked there.
Like,
you don't have to fly to Afghanistan.
You could walk there.
It's not in Libya.
It's near La Jolla
is you call it a little lawyer.
You see these fucking multimillion dollar estates with this gorgeous view and
everyone's driving Ferrari's and Porsche's 20 minutes drive.
You're in Tiawana.
Yeah.
The most violent city on the planet right now.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
And when I go to San Diego,
that's the,
one of the first things I think is how,
what a juxtaposition,
how crazy it is that this is the border to Mexico and it's all military.
San Diego is filled with fucking seals and rangers and Marines and bases and
it's just all military down there sits.
So military influence and it's right next to the most violent,
dangerous city on planet earth.
More than Karachi,
more than Pakistan.
Uh,
we were,
uh,
we were insured by metlife and the metlife agent said,
said something along those lines like,
you're better off going to Afghanistan or Iraq then,
you know,
working here basically numbers wise.
And I was like,
thank you for that.
You know,
that felt that,
that felt like a good pat on the back.
But it seems like they're getting cartel on cartel crime.
Yeah.
Fused with regular person crimes.
So,
but that's how it always starts.
You know,
it's usually starts off,
and again,
this goes back to everything's cyclical down there that that snake eating its
tail.
So you would get cartel on cartel crime and then they finish each other off and
then they realize,
well,
now,
now what do we do?
So they started abducting people extortion just for money.
Just extortion comes into play.
Uh,
you know,
protection rackets
cross us a guy.
Now they're very bold that now they're at a party somewhere and somebody looks
at it and funny.
So they come back and they shoot up the whole Party.
Uh,
I like your daughter.
She's pretty hot.
I'm going to steal her.
And if you do something,
I'll kill you and you're,
you're never going to see your daughter again.
That's how it starts.
You know?
That's,
that's how it started.
Kind of growing.
Just bold.
Brazen that,
that's cruel.
That's how you get it.
Sociopathic.
That's how you get,
say I get to that point.
And then again,
I experienced it back in 2006 era and I saw it get into all the way to win.
The whole of the municipal police were,
were they basically the army surrounded the municipal police office of,
of the,
the,
the beliefs at the Juana and they took all their guns and a few of them were
taking on a plane ride to Mexico City and there for a few weeks there was no
armed police in Tijuana and La municipal armed police.
Imagine somebody,
imagine somebody disarming the whole lop a all of the LAPD and just having the
army in there and said,
you know,
wow.
So you would see,
you would see these events and then things calming down.
You know,
the only success story as far as us as far as the city coming back from the
brink was the Juana for when all that,
uh,
like the raging drug war went down.
Uh,
lieutenant colonel is all of the guy that I used to work with.
he took numbers down like everybody down in Mexico.
He had got hired then on to go to Juarez to try and replicate his success.
Uh,
the only successes were there because he basically treated the problem as a
counter insurgency problem,
not a policing problem.
And he had,
he got a nine attempts on his life.
The last one,
uh,
took the use of his legs.
And he's currently a current,
currently running for mayor of Dwana,
believe it or not.
And he's a,
he's in a wheelchair,
but he's still,
I wouldn't want not want to mess with that guy.
Wow.
Uh,
yeah,
we're a fat.
My myself and some numbers on my family are actually helping out with his
campaign that he's,
you know,
he's,
you,
he got the,
his one of his campaign office has got shut up,
shut up recently.
So is there any plans or the,
is there any push to try to treat the entire problem as a counter insurgency
problem to replicate the success that they hadn't Tiawana no,
it's uh,
it's,
uh,
that was a solution brought in by the right side of the political spectrum in
the,
in Mexico.
So it's,
it's a no go right now because everything's to the left.
And this guy just gotten office.
He's a,
he's,
he's has a few months in,
so yeah,
he just got into office.
So,
so you got five and a half more years of this dude.
We're in for a ride.
That's,
that's all I can say.
Yeah.
Kindness doesn't seem to work when you're dealing with cartels,
it seems like now you give him a hand,
a little take your feet.
That's,
that was,
that's a Mexican say
man.
It for you to have been in that business and to sort of be connected to it,
but outside of it now it did it seem like,
does it seem,
I mean it must be incredibly frustrating,
but it also must feel few tile,
like you've wasted time almost because it's not,
there's no,
no progress is ever going to be made.
Uh,
I have,
uh,
you know,
have a weird experience that I had a burned about two acres of pot somewhere in
Baja,
right.
Uh,
towards the end of my career.
And then things happen politically.
A bunch of Shakespeare Shakeups ever the office.
I got called in and the director at that of the institution that I was in at
that time was a shady character.
And I decided to sit,
you know what?
My,
my mom,
my mom had just passed away and that kind of affected me a little bit.
A lot of it,
a lot of bit,
you know,
and starting a family and stuff like that and you know,
had said,
you know what,
this is,
this is not worth it.
So I left,
quit my job,
handed everything in now,
um,
people were suspicious about why I did it,
you know,
probably found $1 million somewhere in your writing or shit like that.
Right.
So I had to leave in a hurry.
You know,
you got a few threats.
Wow.
Gladly.
I,
uh,
gladly I had,
luckily I had some great people on this side of the border,
the friendships that I developed for a long while.
Um,
and they helped me out.
You know,
I went to Denver about two weeks after I got done with the job and a old lady
handed me a special cookie.
At one of the dispensaries and I saw the people walking in,
you know,
and it's like,
this is,
this,
is this what I've been,
you know?
Right.
Burning and chasing people in the middle of the night and looking at drug planes
and violence and all this,
this lady with a cookie.
Now it's a store.
It's just,
it's a beautiful store in Denver.
There's a store in front of La,
uh,
in front of the Improv that I have to,
I have to put a video up because me and interest Santina were there last night
making fun of it.
I'll send it to you,
Jamie right now.
Cause it's so ridiculous.
They have shit under glass,
like a,
you look,
you're looking at art pieces.
I mean,
again,
um,
I don't know why they're still producing pot in Mexico when you guys have it
having in the stratosphere as far as an art form.
I'm gonna send you this right now,
Jamie.
Yeah,
well,
they definitely have it down now,
but it's just,
it shouldn't be illegal in the first place and that's not hurting anybody.
I just sent it to,
um,
there's a bunch of,
uh,
there's a large,
shamanism and a cultism all rural Mexico and mushrooms and use down there for
like forever and uh,
you know,
growing up and stuff like that,
you would see it and it was,
you know,
the demonization comes from the conflict around it.
Not that it's,
you know,
well there's should,
should be real demonization when it comes to things like fentanyl to just whack.
Ue lists the to turn the volume up so we can see here this understanding
state of marijuana.
And so the California,
I'm inspecting the crystals,
Jane Crystalline,
a magnifying glass,
there's no bullshit.
These are all in glass.
So you can look at the crystals because a lot of these marijuana dorks,
I like wine dorks or any other thing where people really get into it and you
take it too far when he's looking at weed under glass and Julie ideas and be
here right now,
fuck this shit right in the mouth and try to have lead underclass.
Like it's a fine sharp names.
It's just weed man
speaks the truth.
It's just weed,
man.
That's an antique roadshow type level stuff.
They give you a magnifying glass and they had all these displays with the,
this is a hybrid.
This is a,
an indycar strong hybrid.
This is a sativa Straw to Tiva dominant or you're supposed to smell it.
That glass.
Good questions.
Yeah,
that's the right stores.
Have a little jar that you can smell through to.
Very good question.
We would just grab all of it machetes and just put it in a big pile and just
chop it up and load it up.
Part of the wind coming from over there.
Well,
I'm going to sit over here.
Wow.
Yeah.
He would get it pass after that.
So it was fine.
You gotta get a little fucked up.
Oh,
burning all that stuff for us.
The second hand smoking the butter m and.
M's.
That was my,
that
was there a sense of frustration when it was legalized in so many states in the
United States
in some regard.
Yes.
What are we dying for?
What are we fighting for?
Why have I lost brothers?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
a lot of people were killed over finding tons of pot somewhere and now it's
fine.
Yeah,
no,
you can just buy it.
And it's,
I mean,
you know,
the frustration isn't,
isn't with the pot itself,
again,
it's,
it's what happens around the politics around it.
The amount of money invested into fighting it and,
and,
and violence and interest around it.
But the plan itself up again,
my,
my mom used to grow it and put it in a jar with alcohol and rub it on her
muscles,
you know,
and now it's a thing,
it's always,
it's always been there.
They all of a sudden,
uh,
you have full,
full on machine guns protecting it and the grow somewhere and filotto machine
guns,
another place where people coming in there to burn it because you shouldn't be
selling it.
It's just while,
while I was doing it,
uh,
you know,
my mindset was these are bad people.
When I,
when I started,
you know,
these are bad people that are doing drugs.
And later on I was like,
just a,
just a plant stinky plant.
So people are smoking it and never,
never in my life did I encountered a hyped up,
you know,
pod had they wanted a fight,
so I was like,
they should,
they should make this as cause loose.
Everybody would calm down.
It didn't make a difference.
Coke is different methods,
different of course.
But you know,
pot when you were talking about how everyone with a six year plan,
it's not going to work.
It's never going to work.
It seems to me that with the Romanticism of the cults and the way that it's
ingrained in the culture and that they look at these people like folk heroes,
that this is a generational problem.
It seems like,
um,
many generations before it changes and calms down.
And I would struggle to think of what would be the thing that could cause it to
calm down.
Like what,
what could be the catalyst for change?
Yeah.
And more so than things kind of,
uh,
that things are getting even more complicated now with,
Mike migrant caravans going through,
through Mexico now and now you have all these,
these,
this place,
the people from South America now adding onto the problem of an already existing
as the caravan.
We hear about it on the news,
like from Fox News talks about it like scare tactics.
So,
um,
I was,
I don't know,
and people can fact check me on this,
but I was probably one of the first ones to publicly say that they were going to
go the first cabin.
It's going to go straight to Tijuana.
Everybody was,
now they're not going to go straight to Tijuana.
There the Acessa too far off.
They should just go to Texas.
And they went straight to Tijuana and you know,
there,
there were about 3000 strong when they got there and maybe a bit more.
And you know,
a bunch of memes came up because of it.
Uh,
uh,
as they were going through all the Mexico,
most of the people were pretty welcoming because they weren't going to stay.
And now they were like,
here's a water.
Like when somebody is doing a jog or run marathon,
they would hand a puddle of water bottle and you good returns.
They finally got to Tj and Tj is very conservative,
like politically is very conservative place and they met with a wall of
protestors wearing make tea kwon at great again hats.
No,
yes,
no,
yes.
And I may or may not have produced a few of those myself.
And
uh,
and all of a sudden you see the marathon Juana without make them make the wine a
great again hat on his head.
Wow.
And the reason why they were so adverse to these guys coming in is that uh,
they were a lot of them gang members,
you know,
14th street gang members.
The reason why they didn't go the other route is because they would have to have
crossed little set does territory was a cartel that has problems with the 14
gang.
So they were curtailing that.
They were complaining about the food they were getting at the shelters.
You sit there and thermal country feeding third world migrants and we would
feeding them tortillas and beans and there's a famous lady,
it was like,
I'm not gonna eat this as pig.
And I was pygmy,
you want a great again.
So it's trolling on a another level.
Wow.
So,
um,
these guys came in,
but people started calling me the people from Tijuana Racist,
the Brown people.
Do you want to erase it against other Brown people?
Wow.
And you would see some of the,
the uh,
you know,
some of the news agencies from the US come down and volunteer groups who were
hippies,
you know,
with uh,
sending all their donations to these people in some of these minor caravan
camps,
they would grab the donations,
turn around and sell it on the backside.
You know,
all of these things they would sell in the backside.
So we would,
they were,
we had just absorbed about,
uh,
2000 or 3000 Haitian immigrants after the earthquake and [inaudible] no problems
at all.
They're integrated into the culture.
All of a sudden now we have Haitians in the culture,
you know,
no problem at all.
But these guys came in and they were really kind of disruptive in that way.
Right.
So now do you think that it was because all the attention they were getting?
Yeah.
Uh,
that's what they wanted.
You know,
they wanted to create some sort of situation on the border,
so they rushed the border a few times.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
around there when they,
the famous picture of the lady with the kids running towards the border
happened.
They were throwing rocks at the border patrols their border patrol guys.
And that's,
you know,
they got the gas and you know,
the response and that's when she was running away.
Yeah.
And they had a lot of people,
they're throwing rocks.
Yeah.
That they threw rocks constantly.
That was her thing.
And it's funny how photo can give you a totally different perspective.
Again,
anybody that's doubting any of this,
go down with the Quanta and asked the people from Tijuana to want the people did
not want those people there.
They saw them as disruptive crime went up.
One of the encampments that they have was next to a school.
The school had to be shut down because of the needles and stuff that was
competing,
getting found outside of the playground at school.
It was a massive nightmare.
And then we would see it on the news and it was like flowers and um,
you know,
on the narrow you have the narrative was like,
I don't know what these guys are talking about.
Well Trump is such a polarizing figure than anything that would be anti
immigration like that.
Like an anti ma,
they just don't want to hear it.
But they'd be out of the,
the the weird thing is how a lot of people,
uh,
Mexicans like Trump,
you know,
which is really well,
yeah.
Why is that?
I think a,
the whole art,
I'm going to defend our people with type thing that's there like that.
Yeah.
And a lot,
and people have to remember the most Mexicans are very conservative,
you know,
Catholic concern guy.
So it kind of resonates with them in a little,
but you know,
again,
we're divided as well as you guys are politically.
So there's a lot of,
a lot of to the left type of leading people down there.
So they,
you know,
again,
narrative,
you know,
divide and conquer.
But the people on the left,
what is their perspective on the Migraine Caravan?
Oh,
support it,
you know,
opened the borders,
let him throw,
not boots on the ground.
No,
well not,
not that you have boots on the ground there.
Their cities are not the ones that are hosting all of these people.
Right,
right,
right.
They're not right.
They're going down.
They don't have a realistic perspective on that.
So it's a narrative.
So imagine these are the,
this caravan came into Tj and affected the businesses,
the cross border and tourism business.
I,
all the people that live there.
So a lot of businesses actually closed down because of these people coming in.
Really?
And Yeah.
And the only reason they came in,
you know,
was to disrupt and created an international scene,
which is what exactly what they did.
So did they plan on actually trying to get across or they,
they,
they were planning on jumping the fence and claiming asylum,
asylum on the other side.
And the famous lady freehold is that I kind of made famous on my Instagram
account.
She jumped a fence,
claimed asylum,
went to Texas,
and then her and her sister assaulted somebody somewhere and then she got
arrested,
got deported.
Probably.
So,
you know,
that's kind of the story of these people.
And then you would attract some of these people on social media.
So they would be all poor in the Maverick Caravan,
uh,
videos they would have on the news and then you would see them on their social
media accounts from back home that really be Tom bags and stuff like that,
you know,
maybe a fake one,
but still,
you know,
they were,
they were fun thing.
They're flossing,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird dynamic on the border.
And as far as,
uh,
I think it's being utilized in a lot of ways as a political type thing is
currently because of the president you guys have up here.
And it,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but they do make an effort to not go into tourist areas to resort areas.
Then the cartel,
well this is the thing because they own it or they have investments in it.
That's wow.
So like if you go to [inaudible] or something like that,
you think they have investments,
they,
it's in their best interest of have things,
you know,
quiet.
Yeah.
A lot of people.
So I do a lot of training as far,
uh,
do a lot of classes,
stuff like that,
traveler safety things.
And people are amazed with some of the cases that I bring out the fourth that
they think they're going to get abducted or drug by the cartels and some
discotheques somewhere down there.
Yeah.
And it's usually American Americans traveling down there doing their thing now
and they're against other Americans and then coming back up,
it's perfect.
You know,
crime.
Oh really?
Yeah.
There's a lot of that not happened with a guy who killed his girlfriend down
there.
Yeah.
This is a case of something like that,
I think somewhere in the Caribbean.
Maybe that makes sense.
Like that'd be a good way to get rid of somebody who,
a lot of those cases that a mistake the cartel got her.
I miss her so much,
man.
A lot of that,
a lot of the,
uh,
the drug things that happened down there during that spring break type era,
that type of timeframe.
It's always Americans against Americans kind of doing that and people think it's
the cartels are drug and people know it's sometimes it's Americans just taking
advantage of the whole,
uh,
being in the foreign land type thing.
I was staying with my family in Punta Mita at the four seasons and we,
uh,
we,
they,
we have these golf carts and you could take golf carts out of the resort and
they don't like we can we take the golf carts to the town and the lake shore.
Go ahead.
We leave the resort.
The first thing you see is a military vehicle armored with soldiers standing at
the border of the fucking four seasons with machine guns on the roof of this
thing,
standing there ready to rock in case anything goes down.
Yeah.
Uh,
probably waiting for the rival cartel guys to come through.
Yeah.
So again,
a lot of these people live yet at miser businesses a year,
years back.
So a lot of the money in those,
in those resorts probably probably trace it back to cartel interest.
Wow.
So it's just deep.
It goes,
it permeates the entire culture.
Yes.
It's um,
it's,
it's part of the business,
that model and a lot of the money that moves around down there,
there's some sort of relationship with it.
Jesus Christ,
man.
It's Kinda feel free for a guy like you who gave your blood,
sweat and tears and was a part of trying to stop this.
It must feel so strange to watch this night mayor sort of play out.
Um,
you know,
so being up here and most of my friends,
for some reason,
I have attracted so many like marines to my life.
I don't know why.
You know,
a lot.
I have a few see old friends and most mostly just crazy marine guys and I've
been learning about what postconflict is post a conflict or being a veteran.
A combat marinates is through them,
through their eyes.
Um,
you know,
things like posttraumatic stress disorder and stuff like that.
It's to Tbi are things that I didn't even know where thing tell that came up
here.
No one talks about it in Mexico,
that doesn't exist.
It's not,
you know,
it's not discussed now you,
if you go into a situation and you,
you know,
do something somewhere,
you get a few days off,
you know,
and that's about it and come back to work.
Wow.
And uh,
medical wise,
you know,
like I,
I've been discovering all these issues I have from that experience down there
and it's like what kind of issues?
Uh,
yeah,
my nose is pretty,
as pretty,
has been pretty substantially destroyed.
And like my,
I have a few,
you know,
head injuries and no,
I didn't know what they were,
you know,
I just,
it stress,
you know,
where on the body,
it's my age.
I'm 36 I shouldn't be feeling like this,
you know?
And through them they kind of pointed me into like,
you probably have this because this is what I had because I was in Iraq.
It's like I wasn't in Iraq,
might as well been in Iraq.
Well that's,
that's the thing that the,
the,
and,
and also you guys recognize your veterans.
Um,
you know,
not,
not enough.
Not Enough.
Uh,
uh,
there's no such thing as a veteran down there.
You know,
that somebody,
uh,
somebody,
one of my asshole friends,
um,
a marine friends gave me a Mexican drug war veteran hat because all they,
all those guys had their own hats,
you know,
so I think he gave me his Mexican drug war veteran hat and had an eagle,
being strangled by a snake.
And it was pretty funny,
you know,
but then made me realize how there's a bunch of guys down in Mexico then amazing
things and they're getting the recognition because it's a war that they deny.
There's nothing happened.
There's no war happening.
This is like a,
the cartels and,
but there's no war.
You know,
even the current president said,
you know,
this is the end of the drug war,
because I said so kind of thing.
Oh,
so there's no war anymore.
Okay.
Because why the war is over.
Did you have any involvement is barely related,
but did you have any involvement or know anybody that had any involvement with,
um,
those Mormon cults that are down there?
Yes,
I do know people that,
uh,
and the Horez region,
that some of the Mitt Romney's family members in that region area.
Yeah,
I knew some federal,
I know some federal police guys and military guys that,
uh,
were curious about the amount of firearms that these guys had because they had
some,
uh,
they,
they basically fought the cartels off.
How crazy is that?
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's pretty,
it's pretty interesting being there and finding a white guy that speaks amazing
English and it was porn in Mexico and he can there a Mormons,
they're Mormons and they have to get like a visa to trial dos Brittany.
And people don't know that,
like Mitt Romney's dad.
The reason why Mitt Romney's dad never ran for president because he was born in
Mexico.
Yeah.
Ah,
yeah.
I mean,
there's a lot,
there's a lot of white Mexicans,
which is another weird thing that people don't know about.
Can I?
Hello?
Louis C K?
Yeah,
Louis C,
k,
Mexico,
that Canelo.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
anybody that's have Irish ancestry,
if you go into a bar in Mexico,
some bars in Mexico,
you can probably get some free drinks if you tell me your Irish because the
Irish betrayed the Americans in the last Mexico American war and a lot of them
stayed down there and married some of the locals.
That's how Irish last name.
I'm one quarter.
That's how you got to come con Ella probably.
Right.
Um,
yeah,
the uh,
the,
the Mormon community in that area.
Basically a few of their members got abducted and the cartels were,
you know,
wanted to do more against them in these guys apparently got some high power to
long range rifles and they were shooting at these people from afar and they set
up this whole security apparatus around there at a town and,
uh,
the Mexican government,
um,
basically look the other way and kind of said,
vol.
It's fine.
Just don't,
you know,
don't get too crazy with it.
I mean,
there was some sort of interaction as far as,
uh,
them trying to appease things with them,
you know,
because realistically the,
the,
the town that they're,
that they made out there as a paradise,
I mean,
amongst other towns in that area.
It's a beautiful place,
really to beautiful plates.
Very organized,
very,
what is it called?
Is this it?
Jamie?
This is their Mormon little town.
So what kind of military did they have?
Their protects this town,
like if they've,
they've made their own military.
So I actually got to do a few reconnaissance things.
They're just,
there's,
this is passing by and what I saw that they had were a bunch of,
uh,
basically machine gun nest and some of the hilltops and they lit it.
They,
uh,
they limited the amount of access points to that little town.
So they had the bear basically there.
What happened when the people got abducted?
I think one of them got killed and then,
you know,
they wanted to kill other people and that there was this whole thing,
they went to the government for help and they didn't say anything.
So somehow they know procured firearms down there.
So they started defending their own.
What a strange story that is.
Because they left the United States when polygamy was illegal.
Yes.
When they started making polygamy illegal in Utah,
they went,
well,
we'll just go to Mexico because back when they did it,
there wasn't even cars.
So it was like no big deal to live in Mexico.
Like you're riding a fucking horse no matter where you are.
Yeah.
No,
didn't,
no difference.
No.
And they said,
we'll go over here.
But it is a nice,
I mean,
again,
it's a weird American like town in the middle of Juarez.
I mean,
how many people go Wheela?
Uh,
it's probably in the thousands.
Tens of thousands maybe.
Wow.
Yeah.
All Mormons,
all Mormons.
And a lot of Mexicans converts now.
So really?
Yeah.
There's a lot of Mexican converts down there as well.
And are there more than one family and more than one of these towns?
I think so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
There's a lot of family names are in that region.
There are kind of famous,
you know why one of the barons or one of those,
but it's only this one town.
It's,
it's one upset.
There's,
there's a few out there,
there's a few others,
a few Mormon communities out there.
While it's all the same sort of deal arm to the tits discretely armed,
you know,
I don't know if it's open as it was,
but back then when it was really rowdy,
they were,
they were openly doing,
you know,
things to keep people from not coming to their town.
And they're full on Mexican citizens.
Yes.
Wow.
But they're,
but they speak English and they're white until it's,
they don't speak Spanish.
Some of them do,
but they don't need to because if they live in this community,
they don't go out of it a lot.
So,
you know,
it's a weird place that's fucking really weird.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just like,
and when you,
when you're over here and you look at,
do you see it any differently from looking at this,
looking at the situation over there and how crazy Mexico is from America,
like how ignorant Americans are to how bad it really is.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
so I've been up here for
four years now as a resident,
right?
Uh,
and I came up here at the weirdest time,
probably in the u s history as far as,
you know,
when I was going through my immigration process,
uh,
Trump got elected.
So it was pretty interesting,
you know?
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
being pulled to the both sides of the political spectrum,
you and seeing how people would talk about Mexico in ways that were like,
ew,
you realistic or you know,
just weird things that you would hear.
And it's like,
that's not how it is.
You know,
that's not how it happens.
What's a big misconception?
A,
that it's a Mexico problem.
Only in the,
that the,
the influence and the cartels aren't here in the US too.
You know,
they're all there everywhere outside the border.
The border thing is like,
that's the border,
but they're on both sides.
You know,
there's definitely cartel ear in the u.
So then,
um,
most Americans thinking,
thinking of it as a foreign problem.
It's foreign.
If you live far from the border,
maybe,
you know,
uh,
but you know,
it's,
it's everywhere.
It's everywhere.
Um,
that's one thing that I will see like,
oh,
and also that,
uh,
that it's a problem that Mexico she had fix itself,
you know,
that's a lot.
I also hear that know they should fix their own shit.
Yeah.
But their own them,
you know,
the problems down there,
stem from firearms and money coming from up here and big drug market and you
know,
the money going into some corrupt hands down there at times.
And then basically them burning the manual every six years.
I'd just starting a new on their fight and the car's.
Anybody else say this other than you?
Like,
does anybody say that politically over there?
I,
there's a few people,
there's a few people.
Um,
I was actually in charge of the governor of Baja security detail towards,
for two years,
almost three years.
Uh,
I was put there because he was a very good friend of Philippe called the room.
He was his compadre and he was very high level and you know,
there was a lot of threats in his life.
And again,
he was heading up the tip of the spear for the counter and cartel operations and
the whole of Mexico.
And he implemented a plan and Tj that was then replicated throughout the,
the country.
And he would be very vocal in his,
you know,
counter cartel rhetoric and how we could do better in how we should all work
together.
He developed these groups called boom groups,
uh,
basically army,
municipal police,
state police,
all of them working together in these operations groups and just going out there
and it's the jurisdiction of everybody here to do whatever we need to do.
And he was pretty,
you know,
instrumental.
Um,
uh,
his name was,
um,
oh,
tsunami Yan and he's out of politics now.
Uh,
and he had a lot of threats on his life.
And,
uh,
it was pretty interesting working with mps.
One of those people think that all politicians are corrupt down there.
It's not true.
There's some good ones.
He was one,
definitely I'm back at work directly with him and I,
and I,
I could tell you that he was at,
he was one of those good ones.
And Lieutenant Colonel Leyzaola who's now running from [inaudible] wanna,
he's one of those vocal guys.
There's a reason why he's been,
they've tried to kill them nine times,
you know,
he's saying something,
he's,
he's represents something,
right.
Uh,
there are good people down there are willing to flight.
It's just that now there's a lot more bad people wanting to kill.
You must've seen some horrific shit over the course of your career.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
bodies,
um,
the brutality,
torture,
all that,
all that type of stuff down there.
Again,
I tell people working down there as the closest thing to the wild west you have
currently,
it's basically,
and when the people say Third World country as there's a lot of cosmopolitan
places,
uh,
just across the border that aren't necessarily alien to Americanize.
Alright.
Yeah.
Now imagine all this,
you know,
crazy things happening down there.
Like,
um,
there was a famous fire fight,
uh,
in Tijuana.
Uh,
the cooler,
which is basically there was a big cartel stronghold inside of this castle type
thing.
You know,
they had a big giant dome on top of it.
Let cupela shoot out.
And when you,
when that happened,
basically a bunch of everybody responded to this thing and it was next to a
school and kids were being evacuated from and it was pretty horrific.
A lot of the people on the inside,
they had a lot of people abducted on the inside and they ha they basically
executed all of them.
And some of the people on the inside with the cartel guys would put zip ties on
themselves and you know,
kneel down on the ground.
So they would,
you would think it was them and you saw a uniformed police officers inside of
their shooting outside two uniform police officers.
So you would see how the crazy corruption and you know,
la shootout happens.
Bank robbery,
two guys with AK 47 north Hollywood,
that one militarize the whole policing in the United States.
That type of thing happens in t and ma in Mexico and Mexico every day.
And another gap is nothing changes.
You know,
that's,
that's great department and know how,
how something,
how that just is part of the normal now down there,
nothing changes.
No,
no adjustments,
no evolution.
You know,
these guys used to roll around dressed as cops with Cleveland vehicles and now
they roll around in taxi cabs and are more discreet and how they move.
Um,
these guys used to use drug meals and drug tunnels.
Now they use a unmanned drones and other means to cross their drugs.
So they're always kind of evolving and adjusting and the government is trying to
smash it with a hammer for the past 10,
15,
20 years,
just whack them all like I'm on.
What made you start your Instagram account because your Instagram grounds
excellent.
It's Ed manifesto and it's all you,
you,
you talk so much about the problems that are going on over there and you also do
a lot of situational awareness stuff.
You show what's wrong with this picture?
What do you see here?
Yeah.
Uh,
main thing was when I started,
I was still active down there,
so it was kind of like a reporting,
you know,
so I was trying to share things with people to try and raise awareness,
but after that it became more of a thing of I just spent well over a decade
working in this environment down here and I have nothing to show for it.
So I need to take that experience and make it worth it for people at,
to share some of that experience with other people and to make it,
you know,
just to make it,
I had to justify it to myself,
just I need to make it worth,
worth the while worth my while to APP.
I haven't done that.
There's not a lot of people doing what you're doing though.
No,
no.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
the,
the strange thing about me is my English and the fact that I worked on the
border,
so I had the opportunity to cross that border and,
you know,
share some of those experience up here.
Like I've been to the FBI Academy,
uh,
surreal.
You know,
this kid from Tj is now at the FBI academy showing somewhere chits and where
people,
uh,
secret service a academy,
some of some of your SF guys have contact contacted me and I've done work for
them and I show him like,
wow,
like that a trick to get our handcuffs.
That's pretty cool.
Where did you learn that?
Like who showed you that 15 year old kid?
You know,
and Tj told me how to flip handcuffs and weaponize them.
That's pretty gnarly.
Fucked him and weaponize them.
Yeah.
So there's ways of uh,
releasing your handcuffs and flipping the side of the arm,
the handcuffs.
So it looks like it's still on,
but it isn't and somebody approaches you and you flip it open and use that thing
as a meat hook.
And a 15 year old kid showed me that after we applied,
tried to apply that on one of our guys.
And that's the stuff I wrote on in my little manifesto,
which was basically a manifest.
It was a,
uh,
a notebook.
I would write all these things down,
document most of them.
And when I would come over here to the u s to do training,
like I did some training with ensis in Coronado during my career and some of
those guys were a team that I seal guys.
That's how I met a few of them.
And they were like,
Hey ed.
Um,
yeah,
this is how we do a executive protection and in the Middle East.
And I was like,
wow,
that's how I do it.
Or I crossed the border right down here.
Why?
Yes.
What really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
God.
Yeah.
And we'd show them a flash drive with a bunch of pictures from stuff down there
and they would like be blown away by it and sharing information and kind of
basically making use of that experience.
A lot of people down there a mute,
they don't share that experience.
They don't think it's worth anything.
I think I realized that that experience in that gnarly place is worth something
to at least as far as sharing it.
Yeah.
Uh,
not a lot of people think that,
you know,
kind of,
we downplay ourselves.
We have this problem in Mexico.
Most Mexicans are very,
uh,
doubtful about themselves.
You know,
there's a,
like I would have Mexicans,
like what would we have to share with these high level guys?
You know,
and you know,
being in a place like that low means low equipment,
low training,
being creative.
That's a lot of things that come up from those,
uh,
that experience of being,
you know,
solution wise as far as,
keeping safe.
Well,
I think part of the problem with the United States and Mexico is our view of
Mexico and someone like you,
what you provide as a realistic perspective and real information,
real photographs,
real stories go and just enough.
And then this conversation,
just enough where enough people hear it.
It'll shift the,
the idea of what is happening in Mexico a little bit.
I mean,
I again thank you for this invitation and I thank you.
I have a,
like I,
I've,
I have this weird comparison than I have with you as far as this podcast.
I've listened to it way back when,
you know,
uh,
and I,
I remember this whole feeling of being around a campfire and hearing him,
people talk about their things and kind of,
you know,
passing the pipe.
That's pretty interesting.
That's something I've,
I've only kind of seen as far as it changing in the information of that look
like a,
around campfires are shamans or a sweat lodging type situations down there.
A lot of our guys were of native,
so w I would get invited to the sweat lodges and stuff like that.
You know,
you'll get that and change of information,
but yeah,
definitely start talking about it.
That's the first step in a lot of people don't want to talk about it because of
fear.
Now people are like,
Hey,
aren't you afraid of talking about this?
So I was afraid for 12 years.
Yes,
I am.
Uh,
but I,
I know that,
uh,
nobody else has gone into going to,
so like,
if not anybody else,
you know,
what,
if you stop and think about how many kinds of worked on the board or how many
guys have worked in these counter insurgency operations and how few are talking
about it or in how many of them died,
nobody knows who they are,
how many are still out there and nobody knows who they are or you know,
uh,
Sicario that movie.
SICARIO yeah.
Those people are looking at that movie.
It's a lot of the followers,
just suspicious of that.
An ETL total having an MP five,
I was the only Mexican rockin and MP five submachine gun down there.
Right.
So it's like,
is that,
you know,
what did you think of those movies?
Oh,
horrible,
unrealistic.
You know,
they should,
hey,
if somebody doesn't hire,
hired me,
I'll do it for free just to,
you know,
I'll consult for free on that and I'll make it look a little bit more closer to
what it is.
Uh,
but it's,
uh,
the main thing is how,
how w everybody saw that movie and that,
that's how they would,
you know,
that's,
that's the reality,
you know,
how fiction is kind of a basis for reality.
So sicario two comes out and it's basically the United States declaring the
cartels are terrorist organization,
you know,
and I saw that and I was like,
hmm.
Usually fiction kind of pre kind of has a,
uh,
a way of influencing reality.
Further on the line,
you that a Denzel Washington movie called siege where the budget terrorist
attack in New York and then militarized New York,
and that's kind of like a precedent for nine 11.
So you'd see sicario too.
And then,
you know,
we're going to terrorist,
the prompt now says they're going to thinking about declaring the cartels as a
terrorist organization.
That's pretty interesting.
Uh,
mainly because realistically Mexico has been calling them terrorists forever.
You know?
What did you think about that,
about Trump doing that?
Do you think that that actually is something that could happen?
Uh,
if,
if you're going to militarize efforts against it and not just to consider it as
a law enforcement type situations,
I think that people should be afraid down there if you do go that route.
But just realize that's going to be open warfare,
not in a foreign country,
across the ocean.
It's going to be right next to your border.
Yeah.
Where people can walk across yes.
Or make things happen now in there that will affect you up here in a very real
way,
you know,
and it'll get ugly before it gets better.
Uh,
you know,
I,
hopefully it doesn't,
you know,
but that's realistic,
that if that doesn't happen,
if they don't treat it as a terrorist organization and try to have some sort of
impact on it,
what could be done?
I mean,
I think,
I think culturally they're trying to get us ready for that,
you know?
I don't know.
I mean,
I think that's what's,
that's what's happening.
And you'll see a lot of the cross,
you know,
borders a US military assets training,
uh,
Mexican marines down there and having a open relationship with them.
You see that and that the push is to maybe,
you know,
preparing for something.
You know,
I think they're preparing for something.
what,
what could that be?
I don't know.
So the,
what we get about it publicly is just a small sliver of the actual conversations
that are being had.
Yeah.
And also there's a lot of,
you know,
misdirection,
there's a lot of misdirection.
I that I'm personally,
yeah.
But listen,
ed,
I really appreciate you coming down here and enlightening us and telling us all
about this and I really appreciate,
appreciate your Instagram account.
The Instagram account is ed manifesto.
Um,
what else do you have?
Some kind of video?
It's a manifesto on Facebook as well,
and,
uh,
it's manifested.com.
All right,
beautiful.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thanks for coming in here.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.